it's pretty hard to teach curiosity I
think you have to have a little bit of
that engine within your genetic template
but if you can recognize it in yourself
you can then build upon it ladies and
gentlemen Brian grer one of Time
magazine's 100 most influential people
in the world you're responsible for some
of Hollywood's most memorable movies
[Applause]
[Music]
somebody say again please Houston we
have a problem how have you been able to
consistently you know create mass media
box office successes movies that are
that are beloved that kind of withstand
the test of time the beauty of
Storytelling in a cinematic and Sonic
form it can really be
therapeutic if I can have movies take
people on Journeys or Adventures to get
them to that State of Mind feeling that
we're grounded by faith it's not
religion it's it's just Faith you know
it's all those things just about
one-on-one human
[Music]
connection this episode is brought to
you by timeline nutrition which is this
new skin health line of products check
it out and get 10% off your first
order it's super nice to meet you thank
you for doing this yeah of course I'm
thrilled to be on I've uh
of course like many followed your career
for a very long time been a a fan of of
the work that you do and um I wanted to
say right up front that I used to many
many years ago I would see you in Malibu
like down at Cross Creek like hanging
out it was when my kids were little and
I was down there a lot like at the
playground down there and you would
always be around you were surfing and
chatting with people and I often thought
to myself like I would really like to
meet that guy like he's such an
interesting person he's so successful in
what he does and he just seems to be
like you have a compelling presence um
and I never was able to muster up the
gumption to just come up and talk to you
yeah here we are many many years later
thank you yeah no I'm psyched to do this
yeah I would I'm I'm actually very
approachable I gather yeah yeah um
because I love people I mean I love
listening to their story um I should
have my own podcast but I just never did
it well you kind of have been you just
AR recording them you for the last 50
years you have been engaging people in
these curiosity conversations this
practice that you developed as a very
young person um where you were reaching
out to interesting people uh with No
Agenda other than to learn from them and
the podcast is really just a more
structured formal version of that and
you know I can't tell you as I just told
you a moment ago I've been doing this
for 11 years and it's almost impossible
for me to
calculate or put words to the extent to
which it has not just expanded my life
but nourished it in ways that I I I
couldn't I can't
imagine not having done it like it's
been so it's been so nourishing and has
changed me in ways people say well who
who is the most important you know who
what guest it it's just it's the it's
the overall like macro experience of yes
of having done it and being engaged in
in the process of doing it I feel
exactly the same way and as you pointed
out I've been doing it for well when I
got out of college so it's uh I asked
myself this rhetorical question
of what did I learn at
USC you probably saw that and I thought
not very much um and then I started to
reflect on what did I learn and who did
I learn that from and then I tracked
down my the professor that really made a
difference in my life I mean actually
stuck out and developed an awkward
conversation with him during the summer
after I
graduated and I thought wow I learned
more from Dr Milton
walpen in that one hour than I did in an
entire year in his class which I
actually rather enjoyed and I learned a
lot but this one there just this one
hour
was immeasurably better and I thought oh
I can do this my whole life and like
you um I don't know what it'd be like to
not have this curiosity and to exercise
that discipline because it's it's really
fortifying and it's
gives anyone that does it with sincerity
a competitive advantage in life and in
their in their businesses so you don't
really have to compete like I never
really competed with other producers I I
would admire some and and maybe less on
some others but but basically I was
never really I was only competed only
competed on my own
standard and the standard would
constantly be iterating and and growing
because I was always meeting these new
people yeah that had new and unique
accomplishments your grandmother told
you very early that you were a curious
person and despite your your struggles
in school which you later uh you know
realized was was was uh the result of
Dyslexia um she instilled in you um a
recognition of of kind of some level of
of just breed in curiosity that that was
baked into who you are um but obviously
that's stuck with you and you you then
make the choice to really cultivate that
so when you talk about curiosity like
what does that mean specifically and and
yes we can all practice it but you know
people are kind of brought into the
world with varying degrees of of a
natural natural inclination towards it
yeah I agree with you it's it's pretty
hard
to teach curiosity I think you have to
have a little bit of that engine within
your genetic template or in
yourself but if you can recognize it in
yourself even if it's modest you can
then build upon it just by like any kind
of exercise instead of going to the gym
you're doing this other exercise that
exercise is doing a little bit of
homework on who or what subject
interests you and then doing a lot of
work to find that person and a lot of
graling I found you know it was
constantly you know letter upon letter
or email upon email and a lot
of uh um you you know sort of gritty
stuff like begging you know you're kind
of begging assistance to tell their boss
who's probably another
assistant why you should talk to uh
Brian graser yeah and that was of course
in the early stage of my career but
you're still always doing it because
you're taking people off their daily
agenda um you know for me to drive out
here to Agora Hills it takes me off my
con itional agenda but what I read about
you was something I hadn't heard your
podcast but I read about it and I was
really interested in meeting you I
didn't know that we knew each other or
pass each other in Malu which I think is
kind of interesting and funny the
approach or kind of philosophy that
I've adopted and tried to hone in this
podcast is to and it it speaks to kind
of your philosophy of of pursuing
curiosity through these conversations is
to um
I mean first of all there's obviously a
value proposition and you coming here
you have a book out and we're you know
there's a symbiotic kind of relationship
happening here and there's a formal
structure to what we're doing and it's
going to be shared publicly so maybe
that that filter is kind of the way in
which we communicate um but at the same
time I always enter into these trying to
be as prepared as possible but then to
let go of that preparation and just be
present with the person so that I can
allow it to be whatever it wants to be
and to not be uh motivated by any kind
of agenda or attachment to a notion in
my mind of what I want it to be and I
think beneath that is this um belief
that I have that the most important
thing when I sit down to do this is to
try to find a way to
create emotional connection and trust
that whatever the guest has to impart
from an intellectual perspective or
whatever might be helpful to the
audience will come as a result of that
but if I frontload it with trying to
extract information without being able
to figure out how to connect with the
person um that's backwards and I get the
sense that that's sort of the way that
you approach all of these interactions
that you have it is it's so interesting
that you're such a great student of that
um because it took me a while I KNE I
was doing it but I didn't know that's
what I was
doing um I been get would just be
naturally dra drawn into somebody's Soul
basically and and I would do research on
architecture to meet rem coolhouse or to
meet Dr Jonah Sul the creator of the
polio vaccine or even prepare for
princess Dy who
I you know ended up sharing a bowl of
ice cream with breaking protocol in the
process yeah you but you have to like
you you know you yeah you have to break
protocol in order to uh ultimately I
think you have to be un kind of
unprotected
unedited when you talk to people yeah
real a real person a real person yeah
real person which I I suspect in again
going back to what makes this town
rather unique or maybe a little bit
different than other than other places
is that this town and especially in the
industry you know in which you've been
successful is driven almost entirely on
on on transactional friendships or
transactional relationships yeah it it
well it definitely
is
um you know it's funny I was talking to
someone the other
day and uh that was a famous person
actor in Show
Business and I've been in this the
Hollywood world for what 35
years but I never feel like I've never
felt like anyone screwed me ever which
is kind of
unusual um you know because people I
don't know what kind of language you use
on the show but you can say whatever you
want yeah okay so it's just you know
there people that go that guy [__] me
or I'm gonna [__] that person I I don't
have I don't I don't know if you have
this either but I don't really have that
Revenge Gene either I don't
and I'm not better than all these things
I just don't have it I don't
um I can get angry about subjects and
things and work and process and and
people's if they're lazy but I've never
really felt like anyone like screwed me
over or [__] me you know uh probably
anytime something didn't go exactly the
way I wanted it to go I reflect upon it
and I was usually somewhere my fault I
think you know that I you know because
you you have to be pretty precise when
you
communicate um in our business be you
can I found that you can often you can
say the wrong thing but you really have
to be grounded with the right intention
and people have a a sonar for that for
is does this person have the right
intention are they speaking from an
authentic place or a truthful place and
they people really know it even if they
don't know it you know they just go like
I don't know I just didn't feel
comfortable or again it's sometimes it's
beyond verbal you just feel something um
so I think you want to get yourself
together a person we all want to get
oursel together on that like knowing our
inner truth and trying to always show
that and if you're well read at the same
time then you're going to be a either a
good interviewer or a good
interviewee or a good person to say
hello say hi to in the elevator and have
that turn into something or waiting in
the bathroom lineing at at a restaurant
I mean there's a certain level of of
self-confidence that's required or at
least a understanding of of who you are
to be comfortable with you who you are
to bring that into the experience and
you know this is a lot about what you
talk about in the in the face to face
Facebook and now in the also in the
expanded version of a curious mind this
idea of um you know being real like in
Hollywood you're going to go into a
meeting people are going to be defensive
already what does this person want from
me you know their job is to say no most
of the time yeah and how do you get a
yes well you get a yes through some kind
of deploying some kind of strategy and
there's nothing real about any of that
right um that's completely it cross
purposes with being Pres and making eye
contact and and trying to you know
really understand the person who's
sitting across from you liberated from
the result of whatever the conversation
might yield
yeah
um I
always you know cuz if if you're talking
about we're talking about Hollywood and
getting yeses and what that's all about
I always found that if um my mission
within a subject is
something that has a sub is a theme that
is
universal and and undeniably
Universal so for example I've
produced
um Apollo
13 and that is about many things it's
about this journey to to into space it's
about training how hard you have to
train to be an astronaut but it's also
about um it's about A brotherhood
between these astronauts they they
wouldn't have survived if this
Brotherhood between them wasn't working
you know the roles played by you know in
in Apollo 13 so um first it was hard to
pitch that story cuz the studio
executive says well everybody knows they
made it back safely and I said but it's
about a Brotherhood and don't we all
root for brotherhoods don't we all root
for fames
and so it sort of took the executive by
surprise because I didn't even want to
argue the story or the ending I just
wanted to AR case build on the
Brotherhood because Brotherhood is what
you know one might argue that's what
we're missing today in America I mean we
have patriotism as a as a foundational
endpoint that we all want to work
towards but the brother a Brotherhood
will make that work better meaning
all of our Collective appreciation for
you know sound I sound so corny but no
it's true and and if if Tom Hanks is the
face of that Brotherhood you know who
are you gonna root for more than that
guy right so that's yeah I don't know if
you that's exactly right I I wasn't even
going to cast Tom Hanks um you know
there was all these other action Stars
they said go get this guy or go get that
guy or I don't want to say their names
they're all great actors but I said to
myself I was all ready to to pull the
trigger on one of those action stars and
I asked myself like but who does the
world want to save the
most they want to save Tom Hanks the
most what is it about that guy that
makes him so indelible in that way what
is his defining quality people feel his
goodness I just think people feel his
basic goodness and he's you know as far
as an actor he's
entertaining but he doesn't need to
steal the show so he can actually you
know you can actually love him at the
same time there's some actors like in
the case of say Jack Nicholson amazing
star or Michael Keaton Amazing Star but
you know they play
really ex they often can really excel at
very extreme
characters whereas Tom Hanks that's not
what he really does he doesn't really
excel in a really extreme
character I don't think he probably
would have been a great Batman you know
or a great Joker but he is certainly
great at big and he's certainly great at
Forest Gump and he's certainly great at
uh you know uh Captain Sully he's great
at saving the world he's great he you
want you root for him universally he can
put on the costume of the every man and
embody our best aspirations of who we
can be I think right yeah yeah he has a
different form of magic that he
performs when you are in the casting
process like is there a system like how
do you approach that to try to figure
out like how does how do you I guess I
would say I would ask it this way like
how do you deploy your curiosity when
you're trying to make those choices that
are so instrumental in whether a movie
is going to work or not um I ask
questions
that would lead
to does well leads me
to understand whether that person has
anything that's authentic about them in
other words if somebody doesn't say
anything if they all speak in generic
terms I know I I know I won't hire that
person no matter what their credits or I
just won't do it if they don't have um a
point of view that I would call identify
as
intelligence um in other words there are
certain people there that just defy
gravity MH because they it's not their
accomplishments but it's their point of
view you know in the way they in the way
you communicate with them their could be
their point of view about politics it
could be their point of view about
Athletics it could be their point of
view about health care but they have a
PO you know but with they eat what they
do their daily process of life if
there's something unique in there then
I'm leaning in and I'm
interested okay so if anyone knows who
Val Kilmer is Val Kilmer played many
different roles he was great at he was
great in heat he did he played Jim
Morrison in in the movie about the doors
for me and yeah it was very iconic but
prior to that I hired him in a movie
called Real
Genius and I wasn't going to hire him at
all at because I didn't think his I
didn't think his reading was
particularly good um and he knew I
wasn't going to hire him so he waited
for like 4 hours for me to leave at the
end of the day so he's sitting on a
couch and I'm on the 35th floor of a
building in New York that's where we're
doing the casting and he says you mind I
go down with you and so before I get
answer he slips into the elevator
he puts a
nickel between his fingers his open hand
and he starts juggling it from finger to
finger uhhuh flipping it from his index
finger to his all the way to his baby
finger then back to the
thumb and I thought wow that's a kind of
magic unto itself and I literally by the
time we hit the lobby I hired him wow
just because he did that thing because
that told you what it told me that um he
can do he can do something that's very
unique that I couldn't personally
do um he had the balls to wait might
have been five hours actually to just
get in the elevator with me and capture
my attention which he was very
successful at doing it so he was
courageous he was patient he had
internal grit and
um I thought he was ultim at at the end
of the the ride ride down I didn't know
if he was funny or not but I found him
charismatic mhm cuz he had the courage
to do those
things for me longevity is much less
about length of life and really more
about Vibrance it's about living as lit
as possible for as long as possible like
I feel 37 but I'm actually 57 and I'm
thinking thinking to myself could I feel
even better where is that edge what else
is available out there and this inquiry
led me to this really cool company
called timeline which has all these
great skin creams as well as this daily
powder mix that you drink all of which
have this active ingredient called mitop
Pure which is clinically proven to Boost
Cellular energy and muscle Health by
renewing mitochondria and you know what
all I can tell you is that hand of God I
I legit seem to be sidest stepping the
fatigue and the jet lag that usually
visits me when I travel I've got less
energy lows and just more sustained Good
Vibes throughout the day and the travel
packs make it easy on the go so check it
out with a free 3-day starter pack while
supplies last go to timeline
nutrition.com richr or hit the link in
the
description producing a movie is such a
hercul task it's sopan you're pushing
this boulder up a mountain it's
constantly trying to roll back on top of
you it's a miracle any movie gets made
and when a movie is good it's like you
know I mean the number of things that
have to go right for a movie to be good
let alone great is astonishing I think
most people don't quite understand and
this town is littered with people who
call themselves quote unquote producers
who might spend you know the better part
of a decade trying to get one project
made and then it comes out and maybe
it's not so good or whatever um to have
a career as legendary of as yours I mean
what like 47 Oscar nominations at this
point um is is just stunning and so if
you had to like you know deconstruct the
formula for that success like what is
how have you been able to consistently
you know create mass media box office
successes movies that are that are
beloved that kind of withstand the test
of time like what is the secret sauce
there that your that that speaks to like
your strengths that's kind of fueled
your success and and empowered this
track record that you have well from
these curiosity conversations it's
yielded my knowledge or Insight not
complete knowled and insight but enough
Insight that it provides me with new
Rich Arenas to
put um
characters so if I like brotherhoods all
of a sudden I start thinking about the
selfless nature of firemen I don't
really know much about firemen at all
like almost nothing you know just other
than um you know when there's a fire you
call the fireman yeah you know but I but
I ended up making this movie called
Backdraft it was very beloved by firemen
um you know so I think by reaching out
to people and learning about what they
do for a living or bigger subjects or
unique subjects allows me a curation
system to not do something that
everybody else is doing so I try not to
follow anybody ever I don't follow
Trends I don't read data research I
never did and I don't even prognosticate
ever what's going to be successful oh
now in the box office this is what's
going to be successful or next year
everyone's going to want the Barbie
movie I I I don't know I mean in other
words it's a f the it's having curation
system that is bro very broad gives you
the ability to understand what in the
world what subjects are interesting to
you and what's interesting to me just
happens to turn out to be interesting to
other people you have to you have to be
in a place where you can trust that gut
instinct and that intuition though right
which which you've developed through
being constantly curious and always
learning and meeting with all different
kinds of people but but I would imagine
that got lodged early because your first
movie Splash everybody said this is
never going to work and everybody said
no and blah blah blah and you kind of
like in a sopian way push that boulder
up a mountain and it becomes this hit
which then tells you oh like I I can
trust myself even when everybody's
telling me this is a bad idea well
that's thank you for studying that or
knowing that or but that's it's very
nice um that's true it made me feel like
wow nobody does know I can trust myself
I can trust my internal truth you know
my basic Essence drove me towards that
because ultimately even though you might
learn a subject you do have to tap into
your own needs or your your own
weaknesses often um to
find the the character and what they
want and what makes them survive in that
case it was all about Sur man's survival
is through
loveh and um and it's hard to find real
love and so that was essentially the
just the basic truth of the movie so you
always have to have um not a
producer his job is to be creatively and
fiscally responsible so for me the
creative responsibilties is to
understand the heartbeat of what the
movie is and never lose track and that's
why we could make Parenthood for example
like because it's about something that
we really believed in so the the script
would change form over and over again
splash the script changed form over and
over I mean in other words people go
that's terrible script and I'd work on
the script and then I'd get different
writers and i' just endlessly develop it
just often just just tweaking things a
little bit you know or
rebalancing uh the script but never
losing sight of what my ultimate go goal
mission is so you you have to have a
goal mission right and not and that's
the flame that keeps something going for
10 years then you finally get it made
sure um and the goal Mission Project by
project is
creating something
Universal that speaks to us and our
inner Humanity that we can connect with
emotionally and doing that through
something very specific that's
compelling enough to lure us into the
movie theater basically well like eight
eight mile the movie 8 Mile I knew
nothing about hip-hop this is with
Eminem I knew nothing about hip-hop 10
years before I even met Eminem I I had
this curiosity conversation with old
dirty bastard of the wuang clan
I was in New York and I you know every
week had to meet a new person so I said
oh my God I'm going to meet this guy ODB
old dirty bastard I I thought it was
insane name you know because at that
time people didn't have you know want to
have crazy names like that that were
kind of degrading at the same time in
any event so I meet ODB I learn about
the language of hip-hop in the on the
east coast and then I start to demystify
with that language why was there what it
was what it represented it represented
the inner voice of the street and what
was going to become the language of the
youth in America and from ODB I met with
uh Public Enemy with Chuck D then Slick
Rick then L Cool J and all of a sudden I
start to think wow this is hip-hop is
not a subculture it is the it's the
culture right so then I start think
thinking that then I later thought s
then I much later I'm struggling with
this for 10 years I had Spike Lee helped
me a little bit I was going to do it as
a series then as a movie with I meet
Eminem and I realized that within his
story is overcoming
shame and I thought wow I could relate
to that because I too had to overcome a
lot of shame we all have some shame um
it's just sort of
did it stop you from something and it
stopped him from being able to look at
an audience and you know wrap the way he
and to show his talent and so that was
really what the movie was about is like
overcoming your you know your your your
injuries your personal and real injuries
and getting to your talent getting over
those barries so you can actually
express your talent yeah it you know you
reflect back on that movie and you think
it's about his rise to superstardom but
it's really not about that at all it's
about him owning who he is coming to
terms with and and and you know having
some peace about his background his
upbringing and being self-actualized you
know in that through his performance in
that culminating scene where he's just
owning that truth which is a universal
thing it's a very specific way of of
channeling into something that most
people have to go through in their lives
and I think that's why it connected so
deeply but the story of your initial
meeting with Eminem is is pretty wild
because he was very resistant to your WS
yeah he was very res I mean I met with
him in my office and it took a lot of
effort to get him in there and he wasn't
a superstar then he was a rising star
and he just wouldn't look at me and he
didn't really want to talk and so I had
to go to Great Lengths to get him to uh
want to speak to me and communicate so
how did you build that trust how did you
overcome that wall that he was throwing
up probably
ultimately when I got out of
being when
I when I was there was a moment where I
was just super desperate when he was
ready to leave and by being that
desperate it might have uh represented
something to him like wow this guy
really cares mhm but I've never asked
him and I don't
know um but maybe sitting in my office
just as I'm the movie producer and he's
the rising star I don't know maybe the
roles so I stepped way out of my role
and and uh again just before he had his
hand on the door to leave and I and I
don't want to say what I said but I I
just asked him like please you know
please stay you can you can communicate
with me yeah you said anime yeah he did
yeah um and I thought I I said come on
you can animate something like that and
I thought oh man he just he looked at me
he was going to kill me but then he came
back and talked uhuh so it was
great he's
gigantically talented like gigantically
100% yeah um this book a curious mind it
came out in 2015 originally right uh
then you wrote face to face which is
about the importance of personal contact
I think that came out in 2019 yes so why
synthesize those two books and expand a
curious mind and re-release it now okay
because my publisher asked me
to um because I think people today are
operating much more in the State of Mind
of curiosity and if they're not two
things
um I think they are that Curiosity the
word
curiosity uh which overcomes I don't
know the shame of I don't know um the
word curiosity is much more in our
lexicon since the book and I think that
now we're entering a totally new chapter
of what we have to be curious about
which is the state of the world
politically but more importantly on our
personal lives and survival AI so can we
use AI one-on-one to to better our lives
or is it going in some ways to break
down our life either our livelihood our
economics or replace us so the more
Curious you are about that subject right
now or these subjects right now the more
successful you will be in your job and
the more successful you'll be as a human
being and and I think the basic
principles of a curious mind and fused
together with face- Toof face of art of
human connection which is really about
just treating that face-to-face and eye
contact as our human WiFi because
without that human Wi-Fi nobody would
have ever trusted me or sat with me for
an hour to talk to meh they would have
talked to me for a few minutes if I
looked away or looked at my phone they
would have just or if they felt I wasn't
interested or if like my eye contact was
not sincere they would have left Isaac
azimoff well he did leave that was the
only one that did leave but Edward
Teller I mean I've met hundreds of noble
orates
they F I mean I could just endless
amount um those people would not have
left have left princess Dy wouldn't have
broken protocol and shared a bowl of ice
cream with me you know at the U at the
uh premiere of Apollo 13
a lot has happened since 2019 and even
more since 2015 when when the first
iteration of this book came out um the
political landscape has shifted
completely uh we endured a pandemic
which just basically eliminated all of
this face-to-face interpersonal you know
interaction that you speak of it changed
the workplace it changed how we think
about how we interact with people um but
you know Eminem is not giving you the
green light to go forward on this movie
if that meeting was conducted on a zoom
call like it's not happening right so
not happening uh so there is a certain
kind of timeliness like yes your
publisher you know encourage you to do
this but you know frankly and you say it
outright in the book like this is a very
interesting moment that we find
ourselves in where we have an untethered
relationship with the importance of
person you know in-person interactions
with other human beings that has been
tarnished by what we just endured it
gives us an appreciation for how much we
need it but at the same time we're still
disengaged from it people don't go into
the office and you know we are doing
more zoom calls than we were before the
pandemic that's just a fact and that is
fomenting this epidemic of loneliness I
had the Surgeon General on here and we
went in deep on that I heard that one
actually yeah so amazing so you know
this is a very real thing the antidote
to which which
is being in communion with
people finding shared Common Ground
applying that Curiosity as a vehicle or
an engine for empathy because empathy is
what we lack and empathy is what we need
most right now in order to resolve the
very serious problems that are driving
us apart from each other threatening the
fabric of democracy and our ability to
really cohere as a society like these
yes
like engage people with curiosity but
what's behind that is something I think
much more profound and and and
fundamental that you're getting at with
all of this well thank you um I would
trust you by the way I hope so well you
have a lot of hum you you're well read I
could tell you actually read the books
and um and you have so much humility
well I care about this and I'm a
practitioner of these things that you
talk about and you know when podcasting
during the pandemic all went to zoom
like I you know I had to do a few of
those and I just I hated it because I
need to be I need it's not just yes the
eye contact we're sharing an energy here
we are definitely and you can't you
can't put words to it and you also can't
place a value on that that is at the
center of everything like I have this
phrase like conversation matters because
conversation is a vehicle into another
person's experience that allows you to
breed empathy and understanding and
overcome the baked in biases that we all
have and it allows us to suspend our
judgments and communicate more openly
and that's the only way that we can
solve the problems that we Face true
it's a great reminder actually um that
we do when we're together so I'm just
thinking about that um we operate on an
energy or
vibration or on a zoom you definitely
don't have that that's completely Absol
and so your way that you would
detect somebody's truth or the things
that we were just talking about those
core values they they're not really um
live they live in that energy and
they're not really living on the zoom
the other thing about zooms because I
spent a lot of time do you know writing
and producing comedies no one's
particularly funny on on Zoom you know
there's not a lot of laughter on zooms
laughter is is a important lubricant
it's really you know meaningful and the
writer room was really one of the things
that was under threat during the recent
strike that just got resolved too right
like the magic occurs in the energy
that's shared by a group of really
talented funny people 100% And when
they're just doing it on a zoom call
yeah maybe they can come up with a few
jokes it's not the same though yeah and
it's not a problem that AI is going to
solve no it's not just curious to see
what'll happen with all is your what is
your inclination around that around AI
yeah um in relation to which okay uh
well
there's many people in the tech world of
tech and I'm sure you know because
you've interviewed them that believe
that we're going to survive and succeed
better with
AI um but then like who will survive and
succeed better will it be the Common Man
or will it just or will it be the Elite
man you know the the so I don't know the
answer to that really I I use AI I use
open AI I use um a few other sources in
testing the a story so if I have a story
and then I want to State and I want to
write about it differently or or find a
word that I might not have thought about
in relation to the story I had to give a
a birthday speech for my wife the other
day to my wife and so I thought I'll
write down all the virtues of my wife
and then create and turn that into a
narrative and then I thought why
wouldn't I just feed that into chat GPT
so then I did and of course I couldn't
read that because not that I'm above it
or something I just don't think I
could I'm just not good at reading
speeches you know some people are I'm
not I I sort of try I try to understand
the base you know feel the basic
principles of it and know that those
truths live inside of me and then like
you pointed out earlier just talk about
it you have a whole thing on public
speaking leading from the heart and like
just being like how you know honesty and
kind of being real is much more powerful
than whatever words are coming out of
your mouth and yeah cuz people buy that
they don't even buy your words they're
reading your energy and and and if you
can show them your soul which is
something AI doesn't have you're you're
going to you're you're in a better
position to win them over than through
the the cogency of your argument right
yes and so AI being this kind of
soulless thing it can be this tool it
can actually be an incredibly powerful
instrument we use it for stuff here all
the time um but you know it doesn't have
a Consciousness and so I think it's
important to be cognizant of its
shortcomings because um creativity is
our is is our gift right and I think you
and you talk about this also like how
technology in general not just AI but
even you know going online is great if
it's actually nourishing your curiosity
and and and kind of empowering you to
dig deeper and and and really go further
but it can also work as um as as kind of
a impediment to your curiosity because
you think your Curiosity has been
satisfied so if you prompt chat GPT or
you go you Google something and you
think that's the end of the story you're
not really you're not really engaging in
your curiosity and you're not going to
find that Innovative creative solution
that nobody ever thought of before so
true I I because it was my wife's 50th
birthday and were having at a friends of
ours house with about 70 people and
[Music]
um you know I think I'm probably a good
speak I I mean I'm a good public speaker
but I get nervous every time and and so
when I did the chat PT and I kept uh you
know reiterate you know iterating upon
it um that does tell you what to say I
mean it it it re it's using your words
your prompts uh for the most part but it
doesn't give you like what I I didn't
look to that at all and instead of
talking about my love I I I was able to
communicate it in a way that I was
showing you my love so showing her my
what um and that was what worked like
people cheered you know they all like
that because it was it was you know
rudimentary but it was from the soul and
people felt that I showed my love
instead of you know from a
distance just talking about it right
right how has this new era of Hollywood
where the streamers are front and center
changed what you do cuz to me it feels
like on the one hand there's never been
more opportuni to tell stories because
there's so many outlets um so many
opportunities to get a project made or
or or have have a a story told but it's
become our our our culture has become so
diffuse um there is no monoculture
anymore and that's probably a good thing
but at the same time you know shy of a a
big Marvel Marvel movie it's close to
Impossible now to to create something
that
has a resonant culture
impact Beyond like whatever's happening
this
week um it's hard yeah well because
there's so many deflections there's um
from watching a movie there's more live
sports than ever I mean things like that
well there's just a lot going on oh
specifically to the point of streaming
um it's harder to create a cultural
moment with
streaming I think think
now
um there are times that
something really were like a documentary
the Michael Jordan documentary that was
a streamer sure that was really amazing
but I mean you have to be
A++ to be able to create a cultural
moment with something that streams in my
opinion because there's not external
tactile marketing it's all digital
marketing so you're not really feeling
something uh the marketing part the
framing of your
piece um I mean Oppenheimer for example
or Barbie those two of the biggest
movies um there was Outdoor Advertising
there were in the elevator it was on bus
stops there was all sorts of things and
and you felt and would you just felt
there was a tactile kind of
communication with you that um helped
frame seeing that movie mhm and that's
why people I think like you know there's
a Taylor Swift component or there's um
you know basketball or Super Bowl just
being there is makes a huge difference
um and it lives those Mo the things that
happen that are great happen in a more
magnified weight to the culture I think
but does it feel like they're fewer and
far between now yeah yeah yes and does
that change the nature of how you
approach a project or you still just do
it the way that you you know how to do
it well fortunately for for me um a lot
of the streamers you know whether it's
apple or Amazon or Netflix um you know
they're they're all kind of streamers
now but or Disney they um fortunately
they all want imagine movies of the 2000
which are you know like they go just
make the movies that you used to make um
which are tour to force films meaning
you know it's like one like a say a
beautiful mind it was about John Nash
played by uh Russell Crow or Denzel
Washington playing Frank Lucas an
American Gangster or you know um there's
you know those those movies of the 2000s
I have so many more that are just driven
by for the most part a single
performance about a subject that leads
you
to usually leads you to cry you know
either that because of the celebration
of greatness or sadness along the way
and then
greatness I try to leave have every
movie that we work on have hope even
even if it's hard yeah or in or some
form of redemption yes Redemption for
sure
um why is storytelling
important um because it gets you
storytelling is important because
it's it should be
entertaining but it should nourish your
soul in the same way the one of the
great books of all time could do but the
good the beauty of Storytelling in a
cinematic and Sonic form together or
that it reaches you on every level you
know on a cell on a cellular level like
it really it can really be therapeutic
you can learn so much about yourself I
mean I I got into the the the movies
that I make because I saw you know I
didn't know I didn't go to cinema school
I mean I teach at the cinema school but
I didn't go there um uh but the movie
that really really made a difference for
me that I felt elevated my state of
consciousness and elevated me as a
person was
ET I saw ET and the conventional you
know you'd go to movies and you'd fight
with lines and you'd fight with the you
know the vendor and you want to get
popcorn then you want to save your seat
you want to do all this stuff it's a
really was and people are honking and
pushing and I remember at the end of the
movie ET nobody honked nobody pushed it
was
the vibe was entirely different
everybody was elevated to a more
peaceful more um thoughtful state of
mind that was my experience so I thought
if I can have movies do that take people
on Journeys or
adventures in a story to get them to
that state of
mind today I want to make movies that
lead us to the state of mind of feeling
that that there's Faith we're grounded
by faith and that we should be aware
attention to that it's not religion it's
it's just Faith you know it's doing
things abiding by the Golden Rule you
know it's all those things just about
oneon-one human
connection also this sense of
possibility yeah and that and that
humans are are fundamentally good that
seems to you know recur I think that for
sure
um and Wars often End by by having
people get
together seldom does it does that
backfire where you get together to help
demystify one another to realize we're
here surviving on the same on the same
planet for similar reasons um does that
turn into something bad it usually is
turns into something good what's the
movie you have yet to make that you've
always wanted to make that needs to get
made before I'm going to make a modern
Army movie right now oh well you open
the book with this whole experience of
going to Fort Irwin I've done that I've
done that trip where you take the the
Blackhawks to yeah from Burbank it's
unbelievable um my friend Jesse Albert
uh host these for certain individuals
time to time and he uh you know asked me
if if I would come and so I did I didn't
I think you were there two days right I
did a day with a bunch of people and did
the whole thing where you you go
everywhere and you you use all the stuff
guns you go in tanks you do the whole
thing it's wild yeah it it was wild and
now I'm going to go to Fort Campbell
which is all the um Aviation helicopters
and everything CU I'm it's part of this
movie the the um trick
is what is like the movie isn't like the
Army the movie is what like what is it
that you identified through that
experience of visiting Fort Irwin and
and meeting with that General that got
you excited about the story that could
potentially be told there it's so much
about we stick together you live I live
you die I die you know it's really
um it's
really about Humanity basically and that
that it's hard being in in any of the
services is difficult but it also is
rewarding and it also there's times that
because you're sharing you're so
intimate with your brothers or brothers
and sisters at this point that um you
have a lot of laughs too so it's a story
about Brotherhood yeah yeah I only use
four themes yeah so the four themes are
uh family this is the big secret the
secret to imagine entertainment you know
many decade run okay so it's
Brotherhood uh
self-respect like people all want they
Thrive for self they are driven toward
self-respect and um so and that's in
that's ultimately what uh 8 Mile was
about self-respect it was
self-actualizing to get there but it's
about it's about
respect um so it so family Brotherhood
self-respect and I had one other one by
oh love yeah the smallest
one hard anyway on the subject of these
curiosity conversations I think it's
important I mean first of all I'm
curious as to why you think we as a
culture like
undervalue curiosity like why we even
need to talk about it as something that
we should cultivate because it's so
obvious to me and then second to that
like I think it's important to point out
that throughout the your life where
you've been pursuing these
conversations I want to disabuse people
of the idea that they were that they
were like directly Tethered to some
movie Project like a lot of these movies
came out of conversations that you had
with people but they weren't completely
unrelated to the subject matter of that
it's like the it's through osmosis
through just being engaged as way of
being like being a curious person that
has you know provided like a lens on the
world and a way of
filtering um experience that creates the
possibility for these ideas around
movies that you've created so first of
all I look at it like
this the reason I never did a podcast
because people did say you got to have a
podcast is I felt like the conversations
I was doing shouldn't be commodified in
any way that they're really just I was
on this one-on-one curiosity path to
learn
and I felt like many of the people that
were sharing their story with me like
Carl Sean and people like that they
might not have wanted to there weren't
podcasts at that time really and um and
they weren't thought of as so favorably
the early stages of them as as my
recollection goes and so so basically
they weren't attached ever to a project
and I felt like if I approach a
person and it's
it's and it's goal directed that means
it's transactionally directed I thought
they would sense it was
transactional they wouldn't want to do
it I don't want to be transactional I
just want to have a conversation that's
good that helps me Brian and I always
want in I always had a goal in mind was
I am going to be interesting enough to
them that they feel really good about
this Con this hour they spent with me
and they'll feel like it was the best
date they'd ever
had and so I love these conversations
and out of the hundreds if not thousands
of conversations I had um not one one
person individually turned into a
subject it was really just the insights
I gleaned from the conversations or the
little nuances that
I got out of the conversation that
actually
became
um uh that just became useful to me in
some way or valuable to me right and an
example of that I think would be the
relationship between the Chilean
dissident and a beautiful mind yes which
are seemingly completely unrelated and
yet informed each other almost perfectly
for you yes well because what happened
is um and I I'll tell the story quickly
I met a woman named Veronica denegre I
met her through sting who was a c early
C curiosity conversation I had so Sting
the musician I thought this guy was
actually like a school teacher and now
he's the biggest rock star in the world
I mean I don't understand how that
transition works and so I thought I'm
going to meet this I'm going to meet
sting I meet
sting you know he might have liked me a
little bit I mean not tremendously but
enough that he invited me a year later
to go to a barbecue I went to the
barbecue and and this woman named
Veronica denegre was there that he took
on the amnesty tour with he and Bruce
Springsteen she was um held in prison
and was tortured in prison for about six
months in Chile under the
Pino
regime and of course you gravitate
towards the harshest word torture and
you you'll ask like what was it like to
be tortured but I thought I did ask that
for a second then I thought I'm going to
be more interesting than that I'm going
to say how did you
survive because that leads at least
leads to Hope and it's probably a
question that people don't ordinarily
ask like what was the process of
survival mhm and she said that her
process of survival while she was
unpredictably being tortured every day
was that she created a parallel story in
her mind she has one Narrative of what's
actually going on in real time um the to
this torture part and then there's this
other story that's not going on in real
time it's an alternate alternate reality
and that narrative is only in her mind
like a story that she's telling herself
to give her the sustenance the ability
to
survive so I thought later when I
thought much later I thought I want to
make a movie that will help destigmatize
mental
disability so that's very unrelated to
Veronica denegre and being tortured in
Chile has nothing to do with that but by
doing these curiosity conversations each
human being that I met whether it's
Veron Monica denegre or Carl Sean they
they served as being a DOT on a greater
constellation of dots that lived in my
mind and often those constell that
constellation of dots although unrelated
found time periodically would connect a
DOT so her ability to survive was
creating a new a story that would help
her
survive what is this and now I'm making
a movie about a schizophrenic what does
a schizophrenic do they live in
alternate reality so I thought well why
don't I show what an alternate look
reality looks like in a schizophrenic's
mind and that will do several things to
the movie of the John Nash Story one it
will make it
horrifying it'll show an audience really
what it looks like to be in somebody's
mind that is mentally disabled either
bipolar or schizophrenic or any other
mental disability it shows what that
other narrative looks like that will
help us as a viewer have compassion for
that person instead of just driving past
them when we see him on the street
screaming at a car or something or a
street
lamp the other thing it did was it
enabled me as a dramatist to make the
movie instead of a in fact a straight
drama we made it a thriller so a
thriller actually elevates the popular
the chances of Pop critical of of
commercial popularity
Thrillers have more propulsion Drive In
The Narrative so therefore audience is
going oh my God what's going to happen
now in a drama it's more uh uh there's
it's more slightly more
Melancholy and and so it changed the
genre to a thriller which helped it
become hugely um commercially successful
right the Thriller genre acts as a
trojan horse yeah to bring people in and
show them a different perspective on
Mental Health that that helps like
normalize the conversation around
exactly yeah yeah yeah so so that so
very very unrelated and then weirdly I
was able to relate to Apollo 13 much
better which was later because that was
about survival as well and I thought you
know what's it like diff you know it
made me think of the subject of survival
and the subject of survival for them is
just like coping with the difficulty
putting a square plague into a round
hole all those things and um and so the
subject of survival became a subject for
me um that I was able to expand upon in
many different movies actually beautiful
yeah um I have to let you go but the
last thing I'll say is uh for somebody
who's listening to this who's thinking
about curiosity a little bit differently
than they were an hour ago who's
thinking yeah but I'm nervous to talk to
people or you know I'm not Brian graser
I don't have fancy friends perhaps a few
words to leave people with around how to
approach in gendering a little more
curiosity in your life by engaging with
the people in your
environment well look I did it for 20
years where I wasn't famous so anyone
can do it you just all the people that
you know of or know or know of in your
Universe why don't you just ask one of
them to have a curiosity conversation
with you and so it's the teacher across
the street or
or um the insurance salesman down the
street whoever it is you often think of
those jobs as being really um maybe not
interesting or banal but um if you
actually have talked to somebody you
will find the magic within them you'll
find something that interests you I mean
we were on break for two a couple of
minutes and I was super curious about
how you got into being a um a podcaster
which you did before that and then you
told me you were a lawyer and I thought
wow I would have never guessed that so
just the surprise of that was
interesting and then you did ultra
marathon what are they called Ultra what
yeah you got it ultas Ultras yeah you
don't want see you're too humble to say
Ultra physical events yeah that's it you
got it double the size of a marathon I
mean I can't even imagine a marathon
much l double the size I love it thank
you okay thanks I appreciate it all
right Cheers
[Music]
Cheers that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. roll.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason ciolo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Dave Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt Trapper Patt
and Harry mathys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plance
[Music]
namaste
h